he is according to the New York Times
quote perhaps the most famous and
admired contemporary American poet will
you welcome please Allen Ginsberg Allen
Ginsberg might've died thirteen years
ago but his work is everywhere an
exhibition of Ginsburg's photos
captivated viewers at the National
Gallery in Washington DC all summer and
watch for James Franco as the beat poet
and how old the movie the film
dramatizes the cultural and legal
upheavals caused by the 1956 poem that
rocked a generation Thailand changed the
way Americans thought about free
expression I saw the best minds of my
generation when Ginsberg read howl in
San Francisco in the fall of 1956 it
really energized the West Coast Beat
movement America in the world have
become less repressed and more
adventurous thanks to characters like
Allen Ginsberg he is unconventional in
all nanos he helped mainstream Eastern
mysticism and drug aided mind expansion
what am i repo which I wrote on LSD you
want to learn
now cause inevitably he showed up at
Timothy Leary's human being in 1967 he
influenced Bob Dylan
he became a tax protester and advocated
equal rights for homosexuals we're free
it was kicked out of communist countries
for espousing immoral ideas such as free
speech and pot legalization the Marxist
bureaucrat have beat me upon the street
at the core of Ginsburg's and the beat
sensibilities a love of spontaneity and
improvisation he searched for and
created meaning in a vast and
forward-looking world and he captured
memorable images of his friends and
Capay treants Kerouac with his mouth
open as Ginsberg says and the caption
seeming to be chanting of bebop reality
sandwiches but allegory did so much
lettuce don't hide the madness Ginsberg
famously saw the best minds of his
generation destroyed by madness starving
hysterical naked and he left the world a
better place no wonder we haven't
stopped learning from for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
you